LORIN PRICE: Extra!
Extra!
Read all about it!
A dog is now the first ever
CEO of a technology company.
ANTHONY OKWECHIME: Lorin,
what are you doing?
LORIN PRICE: I'm trying to
market my technology blog.
But so far, I can't really
tell if it's working.
ANTHONY OKWECHIME: You
know, If you transfer
all of the data you collect
with Campaign Manager
into Google BigQuery, you can
more easily tell what's working
and what isn't when it
comes to your marketing.
LORIN PRICE: Let's check it out.
ANTHONY OKWECHIME: OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Campaign Manager is a
web-based ad management system
for advertisers
and agencies that
enables the management of
campaigns across the web.
In order to access the
data in your account,
you will need to contact
Campaign Manager support
to set up the data transfer
files on your behalf.
These files will be hosted in
a Google Cloud storage bucket.
Let's get right to it.
In the BigQuery UI, navigate
to the Transfers tab.
And you can see the list of
already configured transfers.
Now we're going to
create a new transfer.
You can specify the
source, which in this case
is Campaign Manager.
You also have multiple
other Google data
sources available,
from Google Ads
to Cloud Storage to YouTube.
We'll enter a display name,
configure any scheduling
options for the transfer, and
select a destination data set.
Now, in the Data
Source Details section,
information about the
Cloud Storage bucket
and the DoubleClick ID will be
provided by Campaign Manager
support.
You can also enable
notifications
so that a designated individual
can be notified on transfer run
failures.
Once you click Save, the
data transfer process
will begin on a preset schedule.
Let's switch to
Existing Transfers.
Select our recently
created transfer,
and then click on Configuration.
You can see that the
source is Campaign Manager,
and there isn't a schedule
as we didn't create one.
Also, the destination data
set we selected is displayed.
You can click on Run
History to view information
about the daily runs of
the transfer schedule.
Next, we'll examine the data
sets where our Campaign Manager
data lives and take a look at
one of the impressions tables.
We can see a sample of
the impressions table data
by clicking Preview.
This table has columns for
advertiser ID, campaign ID,
country code, states or
region, and much more.
Now, let's take a look at one
of the match tables, which
is essentially a lookup
table for the IDs you
saw in the impressions table.
You can see that
in the match table,
the campaign IDs are matched
to the corresponding campaign
name.
LORIN PRICE: Well, all of
my data is now in one place,
but it still doesn't
tell me anything new.
Now what?
ANTHONY OKWECHIME: OK.
Now that all of your
data is in BigQuery,
we have the ability
to run queries on it
to make connections that
aren't visible by just looking
at the data.
LORIN PRICE: What
are we waiting for?
Stories like dog CEOs
need to be heard.
ANTHONY OKWECHIME: Let's begin
to see what kinds of insights
a digital marketer might
want from this data.
A good example would
be to run a query
to provide the number of
impressions and unique users
by campaign from the
beginning of this year.
Let's do that.
The results show us just that.
Notice that we only see
Campaign Manager IDs, though,
and no campaign names.
Now, let's take this
one step further
by executing a join on the
impressions and match tables
and running the same query.
This time, we can see the
Campaign Manager names
by date in addition to
the impression count
and the number of unique users.
Marketing teams find
this type of information
extremely useful.
And all of these
insights and more
can be found by using the
Campaign Manager data transfer
service with BigQuery.
Looks like you're doing well.
LORIN PRICE: Now that I know
I can use the BigQuery data
transfer service with
Campaign Manager data,
I am able to customize my
marketing campaigns much
better, and I have
more readers than ever.
ANTHONY OKWECHIME: And
how's that dog CEO doing?
LORIN PRICE: You'll have to stop
by the blog to check it out.
ANTHONY OKWECHIME:
Thank you for watching.
LORIN PRICE: Don't forget to
subscribe for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]